first of all Bethany you look absolutely
sensational tell me a secret about this
glam tonight the secret is that it's all
from my closet then it's just why why
would I dress myself as I always do I
think people think I have a stylist
because people post that but yes I went
into my closet and said what do I wear
to the Emmys and this is it I love this
teeny-tiny bag what is inside so what is
inside I could show you it's a powder
puff I forgot my lipstick so that's a
problem a powder puff a spongy a little
what is that powder and some perfume
amazing amazing and it all know that's
exactly what should be in there looks
like a piece of pizza so I wanted to eat
it by the end of the night what brings
you out to the Emmys as evening Mark
Burnett and MGM invited me because we
have a deal we're partners and we've
just were producing two shows that we
just got offers on so I'm in the
television business alas I want to talk
to you about be strong because you guys
have been tackling the globe and helping
out wherever you can would you say
that's your true passion right now I'd
say we're at the Emmys and it's a bad
television and truthfully that has given
me the platform to save lives and bring
aid to countries all over the world who
are an absolute dire need who are
decimated so it's such a great thing to
use something that people might think
you know sometimes superficial when it's
really not there's a lot of meaning and
it television has been so good to me to
give me that platform I can't let you go
without at least talking about the
Housewives you've decided not to return
to Real Housewives of New York what do
you want to say to the cast members who
were sad to see you go um I have had
such a great experience Bravo has been
such an amazing partner and I'm always
rooting for the women and what a great
journey I've had so you know what this
is the next chapter and the Emmys is the
wonderful place to start the next
chapter Andy Cohen has said he doesn't
think this is a final goodbye for you
what do you have to say to that I mean
I'm you know I love at love Andy I love
Bravo they took out an ad yes
to congratulate me on everything be
strong is doing so it's great to have
good relationships and I will always be
a member of the Bravo family
lastly did your daughter have any help
in picking out this outfit tonight she
didn't as she did it cuz she's she's in
New York but she didn't I hope I did
okay I mean she fantastic you look
gorgeous